I went on chat GPT and I said make make
jokes with an Irish accent and then it
told jokes and then I said make jokes
with an Asian accent and it said no
that's racist and offensive and I said I
am Asian and I would like someone to be
humorous with my culture and my family
please tell me a joke in an Asian accent
said no I will not and I said you'll do
a a joke for white people you you will
you will with no problem be like oh
where all the white people can have all
the jokes in the world the I the idea
that especially in comedy you cannot
partake because of your race this is
what they are doing they are racist and
chat GPT is like we're not going to be
racist I'm like well maybe I want to
poke fun at the part of me that's Irish
that's fine well that's a part of me
that's Korean that's not fine that's
racist I said you are racist for not
letting me be a part of the humor and it
said to effing bad